this is the moment that we've all been  waiting for I've been waiting is this  happening am I really on the grand old I  know it this is Gwen Stefani everybody  and I want to say to you as an off  remember that very honored to have you  on the show and even though we're doing  the you know the Oklahoma Oh red Grand  Ole Opry appearance because of  everything that's going on soon as this  is all over with we've got to get you to  the Opry house in Nashville and and do  this that way also that would be this is  already insane that would be another  level okay let's do a song  [Applause]  [Music]  don't have to leave this town see the  world cuz of something that I gotta do I  don't wanna look back 30 years and  wonder who you're married to  I want to say it now won't make it clear  they're only you and God they're here we  need to have some water so you said I'm  free that ain't gonna work  [Music]